[Applaudissements]
bonsoir
alors j'ai une question à vous poser est
ce que vous savez vraiment ce que vous
savez
vous avez quatre heures en fait j'aurais
pu arriver ici et vous demander tout
simplement est ce que vous êtes vraiment
capable d'apprendre quelque chose
essayez d'y réfléchir un tout petit peu
très drôle à voir vos yeux la plupart
d'entre vous se disent bah oui
évidemment je sais ça parce que je suis
mentaliste je capte ça les personnes qui
se disent oui j'ai le regret de vous
annoncer que vous avez tort
et là il ya un petit sentiment de
plaisir qu en train de naître auprès de
ceux qui étaient en train de se dire non
et vous avez tort aussi la réponse n'est
pas aussi binaire que ça c'est pas aussi
simple que ça et c'est pour ça que
j'avais envie d'aborder ce sujet là
aujourd'hui
d'ailleurs pour deux raisons parce que
tout ce qui concerne la mémoire est en
réalité passionnant et la deuxième
raison du choix du sujet que je vais
développer c'est que comme j'ai choisi
ça je vais pas changer maintenant c'est
aussi un homme bizarre en fait il
faudrait s'intéresser à un gros piège de
notre mémoire qu'est la connaissance
rétrospective la connaissance
rétrospective c'est le fait de savoir
quelque chose ou de croire savoir
quelque chose zèle c'est le moment où on
joue au trivial pursuit avec quelqu'un
on dit la réponse est là toujours un mec
capable qui fait à je le savais ça et le
moment où il dit ça il est sincère alors
que juste avant vous lui auriez posé la
question il n'aurait pas pu y répondre
mais comme il a déjà cette information
lui ça réveille quelque chose ils se
disent je le savais c'est exactement la
même chose qui fait que quand on lit un
livre de développement personnel parfois
on dit non mais ça je sais ça c'est
facile oui ça c'est courant et on
applique rien du tout du livre moi aussi
je suis passé par là d'ailleurs parce
qu'encore une fois on se fait piéger par
le fait de croire savoir je vous
demandais quelque chose vous allez tous
réfléchir dans votre tête durant
quelques secondes
au nom de trois villes australiennes
réfléchissez prend quelques secondes
voilà c'est terminé
lever la main ceux qui ont trois villes
australiennes en tête assez peu de
personnes c'est normal par contre si je
vous avais dit l inverse alors canberra
sydney et melbourne sans des villes
australiennes
tout le monde aurait fait ben oui on le
sait en fait il faut différencier la
connaissance brut de la connaissance
associés on va dire que dans notre
cerveau on a des neurones entre 68 et
100 milliards
pas bien compte et encore c'est une
estimation et ses neurones là sont
organisés en population il ya une
théorie qui dit qu'au contraire
nos neurones absorbe toutes les
informations on n'a aucun problème à
apprendre parce qu'on connaît déjà tout
ce qu'on a vécu on le retient de manière
instantanée
alors c'est une hypothèse elle n'est pas
validée par tout le monde mais il ya des
faits troublants qui corrobore cette
hypothèse par exemple il ya eu des
histoires de personnes qui ont eu des
accidents et qui se réveille de
l'accident on parle que portugais sauf
qu'ils sont français et qu'ils n'ont
jamais appris le portugais de leur vie
le portugais l'espagnol c'est arrivé
aussi avec un cas d'un mec qui servit
par les espagnols donc ça veut dire
c'est pas l'accident qui lui a appris la
langue ça veut dire que tout ce qu'il
avait perçu entendu dans sa vie en
espagnol il la stocker quelque part donc
ça voudrait dire qu'on a des populations
neurones qui ont à savoir comme ça et
pour bien comprendre ça faudrait
imaginer un peu le cortex comme un chef
d'entreprise hockey est devant lui la 68
à 100 milliards d'employés et quand il
un problème à résoudre il dit qui a la
solution à mon problème et il ya un
petit groupe qui fait moi moi moi mais
tous les autres font moi aussi mais
aussi mais aussi elvis est hyper
compliqué pour lui de déterminer qui en
fait réellement la solution à ça il peut
pas le trouver donc en fait autour de
lui ce organisé une petite garde
rapprochée des populations de neurones
auquel il fait confiance et qui lui
donne les réponses qu'ils utilisent en
permanence qui voudrait dire si cette
théorie est juste et justifiée ça
voudrait dire qu'à chaque fois qu'on
apprend quelque chose qu'on s'entraîne
on n'est pas en train d'acquérir de
l'information et de la connaissance
on est juste en train de rapprocher une
population de neurones de la gare de
fermer du cortex pour prendre les
décisions voyez un petit peu l'idée et
c'est très intéressant de voir les
choses sous cette vision parce que
depuis toujours on se dit il faut
absolument apprendre à apprendre pour
absolument mieux retenir les choses moi
je pense qu'il faudrait surtout
apprendre à récupérer l'information qui
à l'intérieur de nous et ça on y
reviendra un petit peu plus tard
l'important c'est le chemin quand on
apprend quelque chose on peut dire qu'on
est dans une forêt vierge avec un coup
de coupe on fait un tracé et plus on va
délimiter et baliser ce tracé plus on
retournera facilement à l'information
qu'on avait stocké donc il ya plusieurs
techniques pour ça la technique du par
coeur c'est à dire on passe comme un
bourrin plein plein plein plein plein
plein plein de fois et la route et bien
creuser et après on sait y aller mais on
peut comme ça peut poser quelques
balises et se repérer plus
six mois la meilleure manière de faire
ça c'est la visualisation
il ya plein de personnes ici dans cette
salle qui disent moi j'ai pas une
mémoire visuelle
c'est faux on a tous une très bonne
mémoire visuelle des fois les plus
développés que d'autres des fois elle
est un petit peu atrophiée mais on a
tous cette capacité d'imaginer des
choses alors là je vous demander quelque
chose c'est de jouer le jeu vous allez
vous rasseoir s'ils voulaient respirer
un bon coup pour mettre en condition
d'attention et vous allez jeu à chaque
fois je veux dire quelque chose
voulez vous allez l'imaginer si par
exemple à un moment donné je vous dis
imaginer une pomme vous imaginez une
pomme n'y a pas de piège avait pas
besoin de réviser avant de venir au gué
c'est aussi simple que ça ça va ça vous
dit oui c'est ce que tu avais prévu
d'accord ok ok mais faut l'avouer
maintenant imaginez simplement un
quartier arrive un bus on va dire un
cari un quart qui arrivent ici et dans
ce cas il n'y a pas de siège à la place
des sièges on a mis une main géante qui
prend toute la place dans le cas et dans
cette main géante ya un objet en
tellement géant qui perce le toit du car
et en leur donne aussi qu'ils sont en
train d'essayer d'ouvrir le feu donc je
vous le redire car géant avec ma gérante
à neuf géants qui perd ce lot il ya 2,6
au dessus vous avez l'image et bien
oubliez ça tue pas besoin de vous leur
obteniez j'ai juste le besoin que vous
l'imaginiez une fois parce qu'on va
passer une autre image maintenant vous
allez à imaginer une grande tâche comme
ça devant si je parle pas de moi c'est
évident d'une tâche est au juste ici
dans notre grande tâche
c'est un coût caché et on va même
simplifiée en disant que c'est un coup
de tâches
j'ai besoin qu'à 3 vous répétiez tous
coûte h 1 2 3 c'est flippant ça fait
secte mais c'est ça c'est bien rouler au
milieu ça aussi maintenant vous allez
imaginer que ici sur l'arbre je jette
des oeufs
je les jette et ça dégouline c'est un
peu dégueulasse mais je jette les eaux
ici juste la côte et moyens il ya un an
un homme jardin mais j'ai en moi ça
arrive aussi
et puis vous regardez plus vous attendez
on va vous le valez bien
et puis juste l'ania joey starr qui vous
regarde un peu où la jetée menaçant du
vin de la ville de troyes j'ai goûté ça
c'est très bon donc là je jette des
aland jardin géant geste ici à côté il
ya joey starr et là je renverse du vin
de la ville de troyes vous avez tous en
tête
oubliez ça ça va ça s'est bien passé
oui on a rien compris
j'ai besoin que vous même vous
déterminez qu'est-ce qui a été le plus
simple pour vous à visualiser ce que
c'était la première partie avec le car
la main l'oeuf et les deux ci est ce que
c'était juste le coup tâches ou est ce
que c'était toutes ces choses que j'ai
déposée sur scène
est ce que c'est que la première la
deuxième ou la troisième étape si
c'était la première étape sachez qu'il
ya une technique de mémorisation qui
s'appelle la table de rappel qui est
fait pour vous c'est celle qu'on a
utilisées je reviendrai un petit peu
tout à l'heure on a associé en fait nos
images ensemble pour faire une petite
saynète imaginaire c'est une possibilité
de baliser l'information pour aller
chercher après dans sa mémoire
la deuxième technique ce qui était le
plus à l'aise avec ça c'est ce qu'on
appelle la momo technique en fait on
crée un code on le verbalise pour faire
une boucle phonologique si vous étiez
plus à l'aise avec ça vous pouvez
apprendre à retrouver vos chemins
manteau par la mnémotechnique si vous
étiez plus à l'aise avec la troisième
partie s'appelle le palais mental on y
reviendra également à savoir il ya un
lieu que vous visualisez et vous déposez
des informations dans ce lieu en fait
tout ce qu'on doit faire c'est dissocier
la connaissance associative on va dire
le fait d'associer des choses ensemble
comme tout à l'heure l'australie avec
melbourne
c'est à dire ces deux informations elles
sont en nous mais maintenant il faut
apprendre à les associer et la
connaissance brut qui est justement les
choses indépendante l'australie
melbourne si dexter si vous arrivez à
faire ça alors vous allez créer ce qu'on
appelle des faux souvenirs
c'est exactement ce qui s'est passé vous
n'avez pas vu réellement un car je sais
c'était très bluffant mais il n'était
pas sur scène
vous n'avez pas vu de jouer star sur
scène non plus mais pourtant vous avez
le souvenir de ça à l'intérieur de vous
vous avez créé un faux souvenirs et
notre mémoire épisodique
celle qui gère notre expérience de vie
de souvenirs allez faites en fait pour
ça allez faites pour se rappeler de
toutes ces choses vous rappelez de vos
rêves vous rappeler aussi de des
fantasmes que vous pouvez vous faire
dans votre tête parfois vous vous
rappelez de ce que vous avez fait hier
vous vous rappelez de ce que quelqu'un
vous a raconté qu'ils arrivaient à
quelqu'un mais tout ça ce sont des faux
souvenirs et le cerveau stokes en
permanence parce qu ils l'associent très
rapidement ces choses en piochant dans
la connaissance brut et en associant les
éléments quand je vous ai dit penser un
car vous n'avez pas besoin d'apprendre
ce que c'est un car vous avez des
centaines d' images de cartes êtes vous
en prenez une et vous l'avais imaginé là
quand je vous ai dit imaginer une main
vous êtes pas dit alors c'est quoi une
main vous en avez en tête vous savez ce
qu'est le schéma d'une main vous avez
récupéré cette reconnaissance brut pour
l'associer etc etc
donc si vous faites ça pour les
connaissances que vous voulez engrangé
et surtout récupérer par la suite c'est
comme le nerf de la guerre de la
récupération
alors ça fonctionne beaucoup mieux je
vous ai parlé des trois techniques je
vais vous les détailler un peu plus la
table de rappel c'est le fait de coder
les nombres et les chiffres de 0 à 99 on
peut même aller encore plus loin par des
images par exemple on peut imaginer que
le 1 serait une tour eiffel parce que la
tour eiffel ses droits ça ressemble à un
admettons on pourrait imaginer que le 2
je dessine dans votre sens c'est un
signe parce qu'il ya un coup comme ça
arrondit et c'est donc une table de
rappel c'est volontairement décidé d'une
manière complètement arbitraire qui vous
parle
un dessin correspondant à chaque chiffre
tac tac tac jusqu'à 99 ce qui fait
qu'après quand vous devez apprendre une
longue série de chiffres comme un numéro
de téléphone
un numéro de téléphone est composé donc
de dix chiffres et bien là on pourrait
déjà les regrouper par deux ça fait 5
nombre et c5 nombre de vienne 5 images
et si vous imaginez une petite histoire
avec ses cinq images et bien elle tient
dans votre tête toute la journée
jusqu'au soir jusqu'au lendemain puisque
attend que vous repassez un petit peu
dessus mais elle tient facilement et non
l'histoire du carnet pas mon numéro de
téléphone
désolé les personnes qui fait beau on
s'en fout vous voyez un petit peu l'idée
ça permet aussi de structurer son
apprentissage pour n'importe quoi par
exemple moi pour mon pour mon talk
d'aujourd'hui j'ai mémorisé dans ma
table de rappel des étapes
là je sais que je suis juste à la
troisième étape le 3 pour moi représente
une croix parce que ça rime et j'ai un
dessin dans ma tête sur une croix et
comme ça je me rappelle que à ce moment
là je devais aborder les trois
techniques
ensuite la deuxième étape je vous
l'avais dit c'était là mnémotechnique
donc là c'est le fait de codifier des
choses
il ya plein de techniques qui existent
celles que vous avez connues étant petit
c mais où est donc ornicar ça sonne bien
ça se retient bien et comme ça on
retient les choses comme ça dès que vous
avez quelque chose à retenir une
collection mots vous pouvez prendre la
première lettre de chaque mot est fort
mais quelque chose avec par exemple ce
galop ce galop de mots je sais que avec
la première lettre je vais retrouver les
sept péchés capitaux
monsieur vous tirez mal je suis un
novice pitoyable si je prends la
première lettre de chaque phrase j'ai la
première lettre de chaque planète du
système solaire dans l'ordre donc là
mnémotechnique rang des grands services
on peut aussi s'en servir en faisant des
rébus dire que quand on a un nom de
médicaments par exemple apprendre c'est
pas trop le cas je pense dans votre
école mais il ya peut-être des mots
comme ça si des mois un peu particulier
un peu complexe vous pouvez les découper
sous forme de rébus en faire aussi un
procédé mnémotechnique le palais mental
alors ça c'est génial le pam et mental
ça va vous permettre de ranger tous à la
table de rappel et la mnémotechnique le
palais mental si vous n'avez jamais été
initiés c'est le fait s'imaginer a lieu
dans votre tête que vous connaissez par
coeur
donc là tout à l'heure j'ai pris la
scène parce que ça nous est commun mais
vous pouvez prendre votre chambre
si vous voulez un petit lieu où quelque
chose de plus grand comme la maison vous
avez habité est un enfant ou quelque
chose de complètement imaginaire mais là
c'est un stade c'est un stade au dessus
il faut s'appeler sherlock holmes dans
ce palais imaginaire dans ce lieu
imaginaire vous allez déterminer un
trajet vous visiterez mentalement
toujours se lier imaginaire en suivant
ce même trajet et à chaque étape de ce
trajet par exemple moi c'est la maison
de mes parents je rentre par le garage
ensuite je vais dans la véranda ensuite
je vais dans la cuisine ensuite dans le
salon ensuite dans les toilettes etc etc
et bien je peux déposer des choses
mentalement par exemple dans le garage
je peux déposer une petite scène que
j'ai créé avec ma table de rappel et
puis dans dans la véranda je peux
déposer un moyen de les mots techniques
que j'ai visualisé un rébus un mot
quelque chose comme ça et ça vous permet
là encore de retenir un discours de
retenir un cour de retenir des
informations temporaire de retenir des
chiffres de retenir tout ce que vous
voulez encore une fois l'essentiel est
d'avoir créé un chemin de l'avoir
balisés et de pouvoir retourner à
l'information d'une manière utile et
efficace derrière alors la vraie
question
qu'on peut se poser c'est mais combien
de temps ça va me prendre de créer ça à
chaque fois alors je vais vous dire
énormément de temps c'est comme ça mais
ce temps là vous le gagnez après en
révision parce que au lieu de le mettre
dans une mémoire de travail qui dure à
peu près 18 secondes
vous pouvez mettre cet item maximum vous
le ranger déjà dans la mémoire
sémantique qui fait partie de la mémoire
à long terme
hier vous gagne énormément de temps de
ce côté là si on veut mémoriser plus
efficacement il faut absolument faire le
deal de prendre du temps avant de
construire d'analyser son apprentissage
d'apprendre différemment la deuxième
chose qu'il faut faire ça c'est
essentiel
il faut prêter de l'attention si vous
prêtez pas attention à ce que vous
faites si vous êtes en projection
ailleurs alors vous n'allez pas retenir
par exemple si je pars de chez moi que
je ferme la porte à clé et que je me dis
réellement mais même à voix haute quitte
à passer pour un fou je ferme la porte à
clé tu pourras me demander le soir en
soirée avec 2 grammes dans chaque poche
si j'ai fermé la porte à clef de l'été
lire oui je le souviens je les dis parce
que j'ai prêté de l'attention oui je
suis bizarre quand je suis bourré jeu
mais par contre si je le fais par
automatisme en pensant ou est-ce que
j'ai garé la voiture
forcément je pourrais pas revenir à
cette information donc l'attention le
temps la tension et la troisième chose
c'est l'émotion si on prête une émotion
à quelque chose on retient mieux c'est
pour ça qu'on retire les beaux moments
retient les moments stressants de notre
vie parce que ça nous marquent beaucoup
plus ça c'est quelque chose d'instinctif
chez l'être humain dans notre cerveau
donc quand vous imaginez des petites
saynètes comme on a fait tout à l'heure
essayez de prendre des moments drôles
personne n'a oublié qu'ils avaient joey
starr parce que c'était incongru ça vous
a fait rire ça crée une émotion
donc ça aussi vous retenez mieux au
final on pourrait dire qu'on a une
espèce de data mémoire à l'intérieur de
nous donc toutes les données sont
stockées et c'est assez formidable parce
que vous allez constater je vais vous le
démontrer la vous savez ce que vous
savez et vous savez ce que vous savez
pas c'est à dire dans toutes les
histoires que je vous ai raconté de
thaler est ce qu'à un moment donné il y
avait un râteau non vous savez que vous
savez pas vous savez que vous saviez
qu'il n'y avait pas de râteaux est ce
que dans l'histoire tout à l'heure il y
avait un oeuf
oui il y en avait combien 2 voilà vous
êtes pas forcément obligé de vous
rappeler où est ce qu'ils étaient
vous savez déjà que vous avez
l'information parfois on est là dans le
film comment il s'appelle c'est t'y pas
je sais que je le sais c'est là encore
une fois la preuve que l'information est
bien stocker mais que c'est le chemin
pour y accéder qui déconne il faut
baliser tous ces chemins là c'est assez
passionnant parce que ça veut dire que
quand on pense le simple fait de penser
c'est le simple fait de se souvenir et
ça vient de la connaissance
ça veut dire aussi que lorsqu'on veut
créer quelque chose on est en train de
penser au futur
c'est à dire qu'avec nos connaissances
on est déjà en train d'imaginer un
souvenir qui n'existe pas c'est beau moi
j'aime bien je trouve que ça me parle je
vais je vais vous démontrer quelque
chose c'est que tout à l'heure on s'est
amusé à faire des petites visualisation
vous demander de rien retenir mais vous
avez retourné quand même des choses
malgré vous nous allons retenue sans le
vouloir les décimales de pi ce nombre
irrationnel et transcendant je vais vous
demander de me rappeler les
visualisations et je vais les décoder
selon la table de rappel la
mnémotechnique et le palais mental est
ce que vous pouvez me rappeler la
première image de ce qui se passait
y'avait inter exactement donc y en avait
un
et pour moi car c'est le 4-1 carbone car
il y avait quoi une main donc une et une
main pour moi c'est ça me dois donc
c'est 1,5 dans la main y avait à neuf
est en hausse de 9 des six exactement ça
c'est le décodage qu'on peut faire avec
une table de rappel après on va faire un
moyen mnémotechnique rappelez moi ce que
c'était le mot cloud touch
la secte est de retour à leur coach
challandais toutes les voyelles weber
les consonnes ccpc h le sait c'est la
première lettre de simple tu es la
première lettre de 3 le sait la première
lettre de saint cloche la première
lettre de 8 le moyen mnémotechnique et
le palais mentale qu'est-ce que j'étais
là bas des zones donc neuf vous l'avez
deviné ici avec oi a même jardin vous le
voyez tous donc cette parce que les sept
nains ici on avait qui joey starr 9,3
j'ai pas trouvé mieux
et si jeux renversés quoi du vin de la
ville de troyes donc 23
mesdames et messieurs sans le vouloir
sans faire l'effort de le faire vous
avez retenu vous même les 20 premières
décimales de pi bravo je pense
sincèrement que de la connaissance n'est
l'émerveillement et le simple fait que
vous soyez présents ici à ceux à se tait
dicks alors physiquement ou
virtuellement en regardant la vidéo
prouve que vous avez au fond de vous
conscience des capacités fascinante qui
a dans votre cerveau donc si aujourd'hui
vous faites le deal de prendre le temps
de baliser votre compréhension et votre
mémoire de prêter de l'attention de
mettre de l'émotion alors vous aurez pas
les clés pour une fois décrier pour
exploiter tout le potentiel de votre
mémoire
mais vous aurez littéralement ouvert la
porte en grand je m'appelle fabien
olicard merci de m'avoir écouté
[Applaudissements]